what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python tutorial in this tutorial
I'll be showing you guys how to get
Python to open and close a program so
this can be used for all kinds of
different things you can get it to open
up a program and they maybe do something
with that program or you can get it to
just maybe be kind of like a batch file
and so on so there's obviously a bunch
of reasons why you might want to do this
and so I'm going to show you how only
important we're going to need is one
that comes with your installation of
Python and that's going to be OS so that
we can do various commands basically OS
gives you the command prompt next what
we want to do is we're just going to
define a function called open file and
within here it's always good to do
typical trying to accept and in our try
what we're going to want to do is a very
simple command its OS dot start file and
what file we want to start will you'll
specify the path to that file it just so
happens that in the directory I have a
txt file called open meet Texans in the
same directory as this Python script so
I'm just going to put open need text
obviously if it's in another directory
you want to give either you notice the
ellipses and the slashes or lose the
full path but in our case it's in the
same directory so OS start file open me
text so let's go ahead and save that run
that real quick make sure that worked
out for us I'll bring this over and open
file and here's the file that it got
opened this is test awesome grammar
anyway closing that out cool but what if
we actually want to close that program
right and in fact let's let me bring
that back up there is I'm going to put
it I guess we'll just stick it over here
now now what if we want to close that
file it's a little bit different like
you can't close the file based on open
me text and if someone's approved me
wrong go ahead but normally you need the
the pit but there is another way that
you can do it and I will show you that
so now if you wanted to close that file
you can say define close file and
because like in this scenario of like
notepad.exe well I'll talked about that
in a second so again let's go ahead I'm
just going to copy and paste this try
and accept loop so we don't do that
again
get rid of start file and this time what
we want to do is OS dot system and
within here in the system you can put a
command prompt arguments right so in
here we're going to say task kill don't
forget to make two K's there it's pretty
easy to miss a second K and then slash F
/ IM / f means forcefully kill this task
and IM corresponds to image and then
you're going to specify that image name
which in our case will be notepad.exe
now if you had it like another program
that was a different you know like like
notepad would correspond to any notepad
that's open or if you try to close like
Chrome dot exe or something that would
close all of the Chrome's Exe similarly
you can throw like wild carding in here
so you can say like this right this
would close every dot exe that is
running on your machine
I wouldn't recommend doing it but you
could so now let's bring back up notepad
and this time it'll kill notepad dot exe
so now let's come down here and let's
run this and whenever I type in close
file you should see this area disappear
so let me bring this over a little bit
and we'll run closed file boom
forcefully close that be so that's how
you can open and close files within
Python sorry you can't close it based on
file name that would be nice but for a
lot of instances like if you're if
you're using like some sort of
custom-made program or a program that
isn't doesn't have like a bunch of
instances up on your computer so
generally you're probably not using
Python to open and close notepad files
you're using it on with
specific program so it shouldn't become
an issue but just keep that in mind it's
going to close you know all of the
notepads so with that that's going to
conclude the how to run programs within
Python hopefully you guys enjoyed as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support the subscriptions and
until next time